[Music]
justin is in pittsburgh hi justin
welcome to the ramsey show
hey john thanks so much for taking my
call really appreciate it sure what's up
uh yeah so the the reason for my call is
uh apparently 28 years old i've been in
a relationship with my girlfriend for
the past two years and i'm thinking
about taking that relationship to the
next step uh here pretty soon
she is a veterinarian who just graduated
uh last year and is gonna bring about
350 000
worth of uh student loan debt into uh
our marriage lord congratulations
wow so i guess i guess i really just
wanted to call i've been new to the show
new to you guys but i've been doing dave
like things for the last uh three or
four years and was just curious what
your advice would be in regards to how
we can plan to make those repayments
once we
we get married as well as how we
prioritize that um against other large
life um you know purchases such as a
house you know vehicles things on those
lines
that's a hard one man how much debt do
you have outside of that 350 how much
debt do you are you gonna bring into
this relationship uh nothing completely
debt free um you have been saving and
investing for for quite some time i have
about twenty one thousand dollars in
cash uh
sixty thousand dollars in uh my
traditional uh savings plan our tsp and
um
uh 401k
and as well as about uh investor
portfolio of 110 000. okay that's
helpful what do you do what do you make
um so apparently this year just got back
from a nine-month deployment so i'm
gonna make somewhere around 107
this year and then on track to make like
135
next year projection wise
okay
and so obviously your military thank you
for your service
i appreciate it all right here's the
thing
um
the number one cause of divorce
in north america money fights and money
problems money stress
you are walking into
[Music]
a a mess
she has made an unbelievably large mess
and you guys have
as part of your pre-marriage counseling
have got to
because you have an unusually large mess
you've got to go unusually deep
in your relationship and in your
agreement on what our short-term and
long-term future looks like
uh if she says uh if she's going to play
and i have no idea okay but there's kind
of two ends of the spectrum here if
she's gonna roll up her sleeves and
bleep be blue collar and go oh my god
we've made a mess
we're gonna dive on this thing we're
gonna we're gonna fix this thing i'm
gonna work like a maniac i'm gonna uh
work with every sick puppy in an 800
mile radius as a veterinarian i'm going
to work my
tail end off and i'm going to make 200
000 a year while you make 100 000 a year
and we're gonna put your hundred
thousand out of your
investments towards this and we're gonna
clean this stinking mess up in two years
now you got a woman you can marry
if she's like oh well you know it might
take us 30 years and i don't really want
to work that much
i went and spent 350 000 to become a
veterinarian but i'm not going to
veterinary much
run
run yeah now she's she's definitely
fantastic and uh you know i know she's
fantastic that wasn't what i asked
so is is she all in brother is she in on
the work part
she's she's in on the work part uh you
know she definitely
when when she looks at the the grand
amount uh you know our heart kind of
pounds a little bit so i definitely
think that it's uh something that's on
the tip of her mind um but you know with
with our goals what branch of the
military are you going to use
uh navy sir yeah what do you do
uh well so i'm in the the reserves
actually so um i'm a supply guy in the
navy and then uh i work in the oil gas
field as a program manager so gotcha
okay this is a program to be managed
that's exactly what this is
and here's the deal the deeper you
sacrifice in hours of work and in lack
of lifestyle the faster this mess goes
away the faster this mess goes away is
the higher the probability is that it's
going to go away and you don't crash in
the middle of it and the faster it goes
away obviously the faster you can go
become very very wealthy
and you can back your hours back down
where you can breathe again but both of
you are going to be working like maniacs
and you're going to live on nothing and
you're going to drain every account
that's not a retirement account you're
going to throw it at this after the
honeymoon and you guys are living on a
budget that's beans and rice rice and
beans and she's working all the
time
until she cleans this mess up
okay and then one more thing i want to
throw at you can you get capacity for
one more
absolutely john all right
you agree to this and you walk down that
aisle this is not going to be you versus
her
this is going to be you with her right
and so i know especially i know guys who
like to flex and say well if you hadn't
and if you
once you're in y'all are in this
together
and so the shame part's over then it's
just y'all about y'all digging and
building it's not about her digging
something out and you just standing
there watching it as she digs right
we're all in this together is that fair
absolutely that's awesome that's awesome
good man the problem becomes ours and
the opportunity becomes out that's right
both and and listen here's the thing
you guys will come out of this so
freaking strong oh man and you will be
you will your relationship will be so
strong and your your character will be
so strong if you bust up into this but
if you screw around with this this is a
mountain and it'll bury you guys
that's what i'm concerned about yeah so
you got it's got to be like game on and
all her friends coming out of vet school
are going to get new lexus
and all that stuff
they can all jump in the creek man
because they're dumber than rocks
they're going they're going to make a
mess i'm telling you man you're going to
be so laser focused
but the beautiful thing is that's going
to knit you all together
like a because you're fighting a common
foe a common enemy
and you you're knitted together it's
gonna it's gonna do stuff in the dna of
your relationship
that uh the easy times won't bring to
your relationship
absolutely so it's a huge opportunity if
you approach it right and you're both
fully committed to it but it's a huge
problem if either one of you are going
to be half button this thing
so you're like blaming her or she's like
going to be a little princess or
whatever with a vet coat on i mean you
know no you got run
run away
you know that's the thing if that's the
case but i don't think that's her
i i think she's special and um and i
know you are after talking to you yeah
so i think you guys can do it but the
this is the parameters this is the
boundaries by which this huge mess
becomes a blessing
to your
family generationally because you'll be
telling the grandkids with the with the
uh
uh marshmallows on the end of a stick
someday 50 years from now well back in
the day when your granny got out of veg
school we didn't have nothing
and we had to work
and we had to sweat i had my that's why
you're here on the back of this mountain
and we on the whole stinking mountain
and you're doing your marshmallow here
kid
this is your story man and grandma had
her arm halfway up a cows you know
but we got it paid off we got it paid
off
you could have never gone there and we'd
have been okay
hey man
if i'm grandma that's what i'm pulling
out
you went playing your oil and gas i had
to stick my i had to go shoulder deep to
get this debt paid off but i did it
but i did it
oh you are wrong that's awesome
[Laughter]
well that's it i mean you got you got to
have the story it's like when you're
getting out you're driving a junk car
you're driving a hooptie you need to
give the hooptie a name and you need to
take pictures of it yep it needs to be
on the wall
picture the
this is why we're here no more because
we did this yes and that changes
everything and there's nothing wrong
with telling those stories that's what
families are made of that are that have
substance to them it's good stuff and
you're getting ready to build one of
those justin proud of you man